pinball is a great equalizer you don't
have to be a brainiac you don't have to
be a muscle man anybody can play it hi
Michael she signed the founder of the
Pacific pinball museum long before apex
legends and fortnight became synonymous
with gaming there was pinball and while
pinball is experiencing a bit of a
comeback Michael she's worries that some
of the classic machines are being
forgotten to make sure that doesn't
happen he spent thousands of hours
collecting and repairing machines from
just about every era these things are
amazing pieces of engineering history
and art it didn't feel right to sing him
disappear I grew up in the age of video
games and our Cades but I never liked
the video games because when I saw
people playing it man they look like
monkeys on too much coffee you know they
were just I didn't want to be that
person the guys playing pinball were
much cooler this is the first machine I
got as an adult it's the one that
started this whole collection and the
whole museum Williams Gulfstream that
was good for quite a while
then I got another one and another and
another and another I really love my
wife there's no way in hell would I
subject her to a bunch of pinball
enthusiasts coming over on a Friday
Saturday night to our house I think I
got up to four pinball machines in our
living room and I decided I have a
problem but it wasn't a problem that I
wanted to cure so I just just happened
to take her space for the pinball and I
kept collecting so we are in the Pacific
pinball annex where we house the
majority of our collection an engineer
and artist by trade she's founded the
museum back in 2004 with just a few
dozen games and thanks to many generous
donations the collection has grown to
more than 1,700 machines they span a
hundred and thirty years of pinball
history and include everything from
tabletop games to electromechanical
Marvel's to the fully computerized
machines we think of today one thing
they have in common they all have to be
maintained
lift it up you were literally beating
the crap out of them every time we play
a game people you know shove them around
I mean people will kick them that's hard
for me to talk about pork hip hop
machines there's always lights going out
there's coils burning out these things
get loose because remember this thing's
just pounding constantly I used to worry
about it it's an artifact you know and
we're letting people play these
artifacts but pinball it'll take it then
if it breaks you fix it pinball is
always evolving that's the other cool
thing about it it hasn't remained
stagnant there's a lot of interesting
stuff here this is one of the earliest
examples of a commercial pinball the
term pinball came from games like this
where nails are driven into the play
field is for the ball to bounce off of
so their pins pinball 1869 that's when
these were made and it's based on the
French game of Bagatelle he tried to
land the ball into those little saucers
those little pockets in there about 60
years later somebody came up with the
idea of wow if I put glass on it then
people can't cheat when the bartender's
not looking because people would be
playing for drinks or gambling that's
right before there were flippers which
gave players a fighting chance
pinball was considered to be a form of
gambling and that's what caught the
attention of Fiorello LaGuardia the
mayor of New York City from 1934 to 1945
so mayor LaGuardia hated gambling in
general so he had already eliminated all
of the slot machines that the mob was
running in New York City he actually did
clean up New York City in his first year
in office LaGuardia destroyed 25,000
slot machines but the thing that was
left and the mob loved it was pinball he
actually bragged about taking the wooden
legs and fashioning them into
billy clubs to beat these people with
compete the operators who operated these
horrible machines LaGuardia would love
to get journalists to shoot pictures of
him with a sledgehammer smashing these
machines or pushing them over one of my
favorite photos of LaGuardia is he's in
his white suit and he's pushing over a
bow
bumper which is this machine here and it
was pretty obvious that he really hated
this machine in particular because it
was really popular and it was so easy to
play when we entered the war in 1942 he
used that as an excuse to finally kill
the manufacturing of pinball machines in
America by saying hey it's using wire
glass steel these are all materials we
need for the war effort
he was successfully they made it illegal
to manufacture pinball machines during
that era and they didn't come back till
after the war in 1945 well technically
it was still banned in New York City
until the mid 70s pinball only grew in
popularity in the post-war era the next
evolution is when they got flippers and
that was after the war nineteen
forty-seven Gottlieb came up with Humpty
Dumpty was the first machine to actually
have flippers well there's six flippers
these three on this side that all
operate at once and and three on this
side eventually they came down to the
bottom over the next few decades
machines went from wooden frames to
steel the art work and play fields got
more complex and noisier but all of that
was incremental compared the next big
change going from electromechanical to
computerized the brain of the machine is
right here they took all that
electromechanical stuff that was in the
bottom of the cabinet and the scoring
systems and electromechanical and the
controls for those all that's gone at
first I wasn't thrilled I really liked
electric mechanic of bimbo but
eventually he came around to it
the main difference was they played
faster and you got more points because
it takes time on electromechanical
machine for it to make those 5,000
points it's got to engage the score
motor and go dunt dunt dunt dunt dunt
them you know five times on an
electronic one it's instantaneous
so not only other computerized games
faster they also opened the door for new
bells and whistles so you got all sorts
of toys noises flashing lights it's
crazy
they've gone further and further and
further with it
and it looks cute and everything but
when you consider the purpose of it and
the purpose of things like chimes and
and lights flashing and things like that
really it's to distract the player so
computers came in about 1978 they
started producing computer-controlled
pinball machines and that changed
everything and that's how it's been ever
since they started going to dot matrix
display for scoring then eventually
nowadays they have a flat TV screen for
scoring for visuals etc in the back
glass the other big change
one that still doesn't sit right with
sheets with the industry's embrace of TV
and movie licensing the main thing about
pinball that I love that first drew me
to it is the graphic art back glass is
the artwork on the glass on any pinball
machine so that started in about 1935
they started making little short ones
and they got bigger and bigger this is
another one of my favorite back glasses
Williams
stayed away from doing scantily clad
women they instead did kind of
scientific achievements and things like
that this is the first supersonic jet to
fly the one next to it here wizard is
the first machine to actually use
licensing and the movie Tommy had come
out so they got Roger Daltrey and Ann
Margaret signed a license agreement with
them and they got Elton John this time
and licensed him to be captain fantastic
like he was in the movie after that I
think Evel Knievel Harlem Globetrotters
they just started you know doing it more
and more I really loved the original
artwork they came up with some crazy
concepts and I much prefer that than
licensing a movie or a TV show even if
he doesn't agree with all the ways the
game is involved
he says pinball still offer something
that video games can't the video arcade
I doubt because the games were better on
your home computer but people are
longing for interactivity amongst
themselves in a social environment and
they also like the tactile feeling of
pinball
it's definitely gonna survive where is
it going to go I don't know I see
incredible future for because I think
there's so much more you can do with
gravity and a ball and a play feel I
mean we barely scratched the surface